[Applause]
they're up for a fight on an
international scale their armory pieces
of cloth and plenty of paint
the night before is spent at this
warehouse where protesters are
empowering one another before the big
day georgina has traveled from london
especially
we're obviously at cop26 so if that in
itself doesn't tell you that these past
policies that have been created even
though they've been great in theory have
not been practically applied in the in
the correct way
and they don't want to wait any longer
the last week of cop has been
really really disappointing and that's
coming from someone who didn't have high
expectations to begin with it has gone
out of its own way to exclude climate
activists especially
young people from countries around the
world
especially people of color as well and
those who are suffering the worst
effects of the climate crisis already
this disappointment partly echoed by the
young activists who marched through the
city yesterday
in some respects they're good pledges
are they enough and will we see the
action um
i'm not sure young people are banging
the drums they're saying you might not
listen to us but we're going to make our
voices heard
thousands joined greta toonberg and
other key climate figures as they took
over the city from saving the bees to
planting more trees messages everywhere
from those like eight-year-old cameron
says
if not you who
if not know when cop 26
act no
and why do you feel it's important that
you guys are here today to join all the
other people in protesters
if we don't act no then our planet
could be in
real danger
from climate finance to deforestation to
the indigenous communities to the
impending catastrophe everybody here has
their own reason for being here there
have been so many protests throughout
this week
this one today though is going to be so
much bigger 100 000 people are pounding
the pavements
and that's just in glasgow today is a
global day of action
the voices outside could well overshadow
the conversations inside as discussions
of cop 26 turn to protecting the natural
world if this rallying of the troops is
anything to go by their urgency reveals
they believe their time is now
ashnaharenag sky news in glasgow